lo que haremos en este vídeo es ver si
podemos entender cuál es la diferencia
entre diferentes datos que tenemos
dentro de un reporte financiero este es
un reporte financiero bastante básico es
un reporte de ingresos y conforme vaya
pasando el tiempo usted es poco a poco
verán reportes muchísimo más complejos
sin embargo este es un buen inicio aquí
lo que tenemos son los estados de
resultados de dos empresas una de
zapatos benjamín aquí está y otra es
zapatos jacinto básicamente tome esto
porque son dos empresas del mismo
negocio y que funcionan digamos de la
misma manera la única diferencia que
ustedes verán más adelante es que estas
dos empresas son distintas en su
estructura de capital todavía no lo
veremos lo explicaré más adelante pero
es importante que sepan que son negocios
iguales con estructuras de capital
distinta las dos son empresas de zapatos
digamos que
se manejan de la misma manera sabes son
de estas empresas que compran zapatos a
proveedores las llevan a sus tiendas las
exhiben en anaqueles llega el comprador
los escoge y los compra así que vamos a
empezar esta primera línea que tenemos
aquí es ventas y para muchos ya nos
resulta bastante conocida esta
información de ventas lo que nos dice es
cuánto en dinero hemos recibido por la
venta de los zapatos normalmente se
habla de efectivo algunas veces y repito
algunas veces estamos hablando de
cuentas por cobrar en las que bueno
tuvimos tal vez una venta a meses y
entonces recibiríamos el pago más
adelante pero para efectos de este
ejemplo vamos a considerar únicamente el
efecto
digamos que estos 200 mil
han sido el efectivo que recibió cada
una de estas tiendas por la venta de sus
zapatos
el siguiente renglón es el costo de
bienes vendidos y esto es lo que se
refiere es el costo que a nosotros nos
representa vender estos productos en la
tienda es decir si tuviéramos un par de
zapatos que tuvieran un precio final de
100 pesos nosotros tendríamos en 100
pesos estos zapatos sin embargo al
proveedor de los zapatos a los señores
que manufactura en estos zapatos
nosotros les hemos de pagar 50 pesos ese
es el costo que consideraremos en este
caso por la venta de 200 mil nosotros
hemos de pagarle a nuestros proveedores
100 mil aquí verán el signo de menos
para indicar que esto será una resta
este será el costo que nos representa
los bienes que hemos vendido si nosotros
al total de ingresos le restamos el
costo de bienes vendidos tendremos este
dato que se llama ganancia bruta y de
hecho el objetivo de este vídeo es que
podamos entender la diferencia entre lo
que es una ganancia bruta la ganancia
operativa la ganancia antes de impuestos
o una ganancia neta la utilidad bruta es
la primera vez que podemos pensar en una
ganancia o utilidad y la razón por la
que se llama así es que la manera
primaria que tenemos una ganancia al
quitar los costos de la venta de este
zapato algunas veces se consideran otros
gastos tales como publicidad o algunos
costos asociados con la tienda para este
ejemplo es únicamente la ganancia
directa de la venta de este zapato y se
llama bruta porque aún no hemos
eliminado otras
de hecho vamos a ir avanzando en este
vídeo y poco a poco iremos restando
algunos otros rubros
ahora debajo de esta línea de ganancia
bruta lo que vamos a tener son otros
gastos vamos a ponerlos con otro color
vamos a ir restando otros gastos que nos
representan la venta de estos productos
y son el tipo de gastos en los que
incurrimos en respecto a tener
funcionando la tienda por ejemplo
tenemos la renta los salarios la
amortización y depreciación digamos que
están amortizando o despreciando la
máquina registradora o tal vez los
anaqueles el mobiliario y otras cosas
utilitarias y podemos ver que aquí ambos
negocios son idénticos hasta este
momento tenemos la misma renta tenemos
salario amortización y otros hasta el
momento siguen exactamente iguales ambos
negocios si nosotros vamos restándole a
la ganancia bruta cada uno de estos
conceptos aquí tenemos las restas
tendremos entonces la ganancia operativa
esta será la segunda categoría de
ganancia que estamos distinguiendo en
este vídeo
la utilidad de operación o ganancia
operativa sigue siendo exactamente el
mismo número en ambos lo que esto nos
dice es que tanta utilidad tenemos del
negocio es antes de saber cómo está
constituido el negocio simplemente es
que tan rentable nos está resultando
tener este negocio aquí aún no sabemos
si hay intereses de alguna cuenta
bancaria a recibir o sea intereses por
alguna deuda o préstamo es únicamente
del negocio como tal son iguales en
ambas empresas todavía se alcanza a ver
aquí que nuestra ganancia operativa
tanto para zapatos benjamín como para
zapatos jacinto sigue siendo de 33.000
donde empieza a diferenciarse es debajo
de esta línea de la ganancia operativa y
de hecho vamos a poner esta otra línea
hasta aquí
pongamos un color distinto
hasta esta línea vamos a marcarla aquí
estaremos hablando del estado de
resultados abajo de esto hablaremos de
una hoja de balance de hecho sus hojas
de balance son idénticas con la
excepción de que los zapatos jacinto
tienen aquí una deuda de 100.000 digamos
dólares esta es una deuda que zapatos
benjamín no tienen sin mí
vamos a ponerlo bien
100.000 de
y esto no se está modificando todo les
mencionaba que zapatos benjamín no la
tiene
por lo tanto zapatos de benjamín tampoco
pagará intereses respecto a la deuda que
tiene
sin embargo zapatos jacinto si ellos
tienen esta deuda que hemos mencionado y
pagarán 10 mil dólares de intereses
debido a la deuda que tiene
si se fijan estos 10.000 dólares son el
10 por ciento de la deuda que tiene
están pagando algo así como el 10 por
ciento de intereses anual y es aquí
donde empiezan a diferenciarse el resto
de los datos que tendremos para ambas
empresas pusimos estos 10 mil de
intereses debajo de la línea de la
ganancia operativa porque no tiene nada
que ver con el negocio como tal la forma
de operar del negocio es exactamente
idéntica en las dos sin embargo la
estructura viene después de la ganancia
operativa y es cuando tenemos estos
10.000 dólares en los zapatos jacint si
nosotros a la ganancia operativa le
restamos lo correspondiente a ello
tendremos para zapatos benjamín 33.000
dólares mientras que para zapatos
jacinto tendremos 23 mil dólares por la
resta del pago de intereses que tenemos
debido a la deuda ahora tendremos
nuestra ganancia antes de impuestos
esta ganancia antes de impuestos lo que
haremos es pagar muy puntualmente
nuestros impuestos y estos son los
impuestos que cada uno de los dos
negocios paga 11 mil 558 mil 50 de tal
manera que si restamos los impuestos a
esta ganancia previa impuestos tendremos
la ganancia neta y esta ganancia neta
será la que finalmente se irá directo a
los dueños de la empresa